really Joe we told you to play like
seven times like oh [__] hold on I'm
jerking off out here I didn't know but
again Joe we told you he keeps saying
[Music]
so uh a man has been arrested after
throwing eggs at King's King Charles and
the queen consort during a public visit
um and he's been charged with the
offense and banned from carrying eggs
how are they gonna police that by the
way right that's my first question you
gotta follow him you gotta put it you
gotta put a [__] put him on egg watch
egg tail I'm gonna put a Bobby on him
like 24 7. a Bobby or every single
grocery store has his [__] photo
printed or something like that no egg
when he tries to check the eggs out
they're like sorry sir we can't sell you
these that sucks so uh Patrick fell well
age 23 says he's the man who was
arrested after eggs were thrown at the
King was a student at the University of
York and he said he was held by police
for several hours quote I was let out at
10 pm so it wasn't that bad really my
friends were waiting for me what a g
after I was arrested the experience of
that crowd uh literally screaming and
wailing with pure rage saying that my
head should be on a spike that I should
be murdered on the spot it doesn't phase
me because I understand what fascism is
what it looks like people were ripping
chunks of my hair out they were spinning
at me people lost their minds so it was
a statement by him to be like very
anti-fascist and everything like that
that's kind of cool throw eggs at the
king and queen you should throw a
lettuce next King Charles right yeah it
just keeps getting banned for throwing
the item next is throwing next is
lettuce lettuce tomatoes there's no way
that you're gonna prevent a university
student from not having eggs
it's carrying eggs in public oh okay so
how would he get it home
so he kept eggs be an exhibitionist
look at his wholesome laugh see that's
how you connect this reminds me of all
the activists trying to throw [__] on
paintings that already are covered in
glass oh yeah and then and then right
after the put glue on their hands right
no the cool thing is is we saw those
activists knew that they made sure there
was glass oh really yeah they didn't
they didn't actually want to damage the
painting they just wanted to make the
statement for sure yeah yeah they they
made sure they only did it to the glass
covered ones oh I would assume also
though if an activist did that and it
wasn't like protected and they really
[__] up an ancient painting that had
nothing to do with the the things that
they're talking about that would subtle
warming would end yeah I agree global
warming everybody would get it
everybody would understand climate
change all you gotta do is [__] a
Picasso up that's it and all of a sudden
No One's Gonna Drive anymore they're
like you know what it's either this car
or Picasso and I don't want the [__]
Picasso ruined yeah I'm not gonna do
this a lot of big art fans out there
yeah people don't know that I always
wonder how fast Like Glue will dry from
like like a wonderful glue yeah you know
what it is yeah it drives fast it'll be
like the commercial where the guy has a
helmet and he's on the roof where they
did that and they had to go to the
bathroom so they were crying oh yeah
they were cut really yeah they have to
PPE yeah they're bad at prep they should
have just let them do it because they're
humans at the end of the day man so
funny damn that's deep that's that's
[__] funny but did any of the eggs
hit King Charles or whatever yeah did
they Bean them yeah did they get them
right on the forehead did they get the
crown at all not at all damn not at all
no one likes Charles though apparently
[__] these people in the crowd did
they're [__] rip this guy's hair out
after yeah and spitting on and tell him
that he should die for what he did I
missed the queen she was so she was a
cute little old lady what's the
workaround for if you were banned from
public eggs like how do you get the eggs
home like what's the way apparently
there's like some sort of like uh little
thing in there some sort of little
anecdote that says that you can by way
of groceries like purchase it says uh
not being allowed to possess eggs in
public blah blah you gotta do it like in
British style like
my way of grocery
[Music]
I was about to do it or the [__]
Bobby guy follow him around all day he's
like oh so you've got some eggs there
what do you plan to do with this he's
like some [__] creepy guard uh I'm
gonna eat them
over oh don't think you've learned to
eat those
the henchman's psychic yeah Hunchback
Bobby I know exactly what that guy looks
like right he's like a little lecherous
guy yeah yeah yeah yeah asked why he
targeted the king Slytherin he's got an
egg fetish who has been trying to raise
awareness about climate change for
decades he said if that is what we take
as someone who has done the most for
climate change it shows you how low the
bar is this is amazing I'm sick of
climate change this makes me want to
burn down the planet even more do you
believe it's a thing yeah but it's also
like there's some scientists that talk
about it and they say if you pull back
far enough it's like yeah the the Earth
is constantly like in Men In Black at
the end see there it is dude my whole
thing is where where was this excuse
when I was vandalizing [__] as a kid
I wish I was that smart right that's
good [__] caught with graffiti and
you're like I'm not tagging I'm tagging
for peace oh [__] my bad respect the
kids who are smashing milk jugs at the
store yeah they say hey I said some
climate change I know dude that's so
crazy yeah I would have loved to
bandwagon that [__] as a team yeah
you're just like this for Peter [__] oh
when you're taking a bunch of [__]
silver or plasma or force and put them
in the ground yeah I think you got your
share of things like that
climate change yeah but I didn't have a
good excuse oh that's true dude you go
in the store you lick the ice cream you
put it back like climate change what do
you think the uh the world issue would
have been as your excuse for the forks
if you got caught the world issue back
then what do you think you would have
been anti-plastic Iraq war dude you
gotta make a statement sure yeah you
know this guy also says um he talks
about how Charles this is a man who
dresses in stolen jewels from India and
Africa and every other colony oh that
they're going back to that huh yeah
um you just become a [__] cat burglar
and take the jewels back yeah idiot why
don't you do an Italian job on the
[__] Jewel idiot it's because you
clearly have no skills
I don't think he wants him bad enough
man yeah he he's just he's all talking
he wants something bad enough you Heist
yeah you get a team together you get a
tech guy how come on the jewel thieves
are all in Europe and we don't have them
here because you have to be be like a
dashing gentleman
because when they do it yeah and they
have such a cool like like Escape Plan
like one guy jumps on the back of a
motorcycle and then they go off and they
jump into a boat and [__] and whatever
and they throw it into this [__]
Grandma's basket and then from there
just like man it's so cool all right
we're all in a heist right now we're all
we're all prepping for a heist who's
holding what role can I be the Adidas
guy I want to be the idea okay don't do
anything no Steve's on the computer he's
like hold on hold on I'm in hey guys
yeah I'm with you I'm in the system
right now I got my VPN on I'm hacked in
this Direction all right hey that's good
you always need that in the red dress
classic yeah the honey pot the honey
honey pot honey pie Ryan's the Italian
guy that bumps into you and he's like
hey I'm walking here but then you walk
away and he's like I gotta thank you
I'm the sleight of hand pickpocket
Dick's the guy who's sweating in the
Elevator Shaft is trying to get through
and he's like come on guys give me
another minute I wipe my [__] hand
like oh [__] the [__] codes this is
not what's on my head I'm like I'm like
the homeless guy that looks like he's a
part of the city but they're like
pushing a basket and [__] Joe's naked
pushing the basket he's beating off and
then we're like Joe you're supposed to
be the point guy and then Joe's like
what oh [__] I'm jerking off out here
look Joe we told you to play like seven
times he's like oh [__] hold on I'm
jerking off out here I didn't know okay
Joe we told you he keeps saying now we
have everybody at the outside there's
nobody on the inside Joe there's nobody
to steal the jewel I still haven't had
sex cause I gotta talk to [__] Steve
so I'm blunt making with it
we're all Breaking Down The Plan before
we got 701 you're in the elevator Chef
703 Honeypot goes out 705 Joe's like I'm
jerking off in the pocket I'm like no
[__] sake Joe you're not jerking off
in the park you're the point in it
you're going into the safe they're going
in the [__] safe because somebody has
to steal the jewels and he goes so then
I jerk off after like no Joe I love the
idea that we all gave ourselves roles
except for the guy who takes the actual
job so it's so successful
Anthony removes the jewels dude who owns
all the Lookouts
yeah we're all like exterior rolls
everybody main theme
he's like why didn't we send a dancer in
to go around the laser
we have like seven [__] dancers
one dude no that's can Dude cans in
there going like this [__] deleting
all the footage of all the cameras in
the [__] building
on that job they'll never find one lick
of food it deletes a little camera
footage
and then afterwards the investigation of
like how the [__] did he do that there's
nobody that can move this fast nobody
will tell you I've never seen files
delete that quickly in my whole career
we only got two good angles now one one
angle is completely gone they're like
look at this it almost looks like he's
transferring the data but he's really
deleting it
he's rude it's genius
and then oh dude no the best thing is we
put Bart bar was the point man but then
Bart's like nah I gotta protect her to
bed
until this is like an hour after we
already started he's like guys no he's
like wait this is it's 7 30. I thought
the high school was at 8 A.M not 8 P.M I
woke up at 3 30. yeah is that well my
flight's at four I had to work out
and then bars just like this